es lo que nosotros hicimos y lo que yo
asumo y lo que quiero mantener ahora es
ante los precios de la energía como lo
dijo el señor en un escudo que significa
bloquear los precios la electricidad y
el gas y eso es dos veces más eficaz que
reducir el iva y me permito decir que
los franceses las francesas tendrán un
aumento de sus facturas de algunas
decenas o incluso cientos de euros si
ustedes la eligen porque usted votó en
contra de este escudo energético
entonces cuando uno bloquea un aumento
que es de 40 60 o 100 por ciento para
algunas energías pues entonces
terminamos con unas cifras que son
problemáticos entonces lo primero es
mantener este escudo tan tanto como sea
posible mientras esté la crisis y es un
dispositivo de crisis y esa es la
diferencia con usted la segunda es que
es más eficaz dos veces más que usted lo
segundo es que no espérenme como usted
lo describió es un dispositivo de crisis
cuando regresemos a precios
tradicionales yo asumo no puedo no
seguir subvencionando
gas y el petróleo que no producimos sino
ayudar a las personas y las familias
para poder cambiar de vehículo para
salir de las energías posibles como
comenzamos a hacer y es una estrategia
que quiero continuar lo segundo es el
trabajo yo me siento orgulloso de que
todos juntos podamos o nos hayamos
permitido crear 12 millones de
empleos de pagos porque yo acabo de
mirar su programa y ni siquiera existe
la palabra desempleo ahí es un
reconocimiento del trabajo bien hecho
para los próximos
de los cinco años que acaban de pasar
pero la mejor manera de tener poder
adquisitivo para luchar contra el
desempleo bajamos de dos puntos ese
desempleo y son más de 100.000 los que
encontraron empleo si quiero ir más allá
el salario mínimo será aumentado de 34
euros por mes y también para él
y
las pensiones promedio se ven aumentadas
en 60
euros por mes es una revalorización a
partir de el verano porque no vamos a
esperar como el año pasado a llegar
hasta enero porque ahora tenemos una
inflación de más del 4% y para las
pequeñas pensiones quiero llevarlas a
1100 euros para bien que tengo una
carrera completa en contrario usted
quiere dejar en mil euros y para todos
los trabajadores hay un punto muy
importante y es lo que yo llamo el
dividendo de los asalariados es cuando
un patrón que ya sea un gran grupo o una
empresa pequeña mediana o muy pequeña
debe darle la participación y vamos a
[Música]
dependiendo de los problemas de poder
adquisitivo y la prima de poder
adquisitivo que será llevada a seis mil
euros sin impuestos para los asalariados
es una prima que creamos hace tres años
y ahora será un mecanismo obligatorio
que nos tocará a todos